okay
so is that kind of uh the middle of the
state
pretty much
we're about halfway between indianapolis
and cincinnati so
okay
all right so cincinnati that's kind of
the southern part of ohio yes okay
all right
middle of nowhere
well nothing's in the middle of nowhere
everything's in the middle of where we
are right that's true
that's hardly nowhere it's the most
important place
so what's your weather doing there
it is nice outside now we've had rain
the last couple days but
so far looks like it turned out to be a
good day all good yeah we got rain here
we've had good weather for a while but
it's raining now
that's what it does in vancouver a lot
we're used to it
so are we waiting for one more person
mark yeah we are uh but we can just get
started okay uh
uh yeah okay isaac welcome
um
uh as you say or
from indiana we're in vancouver
i hope everybody's staying safe welcome
to another one of our link gatherings
uh still hoping for
de waal to join us but i don't see him
yet
um
[Music]
and uh
yeah with that maybe isaac
why don't you just start again introduce
yourself let us know which languages
well you know what i thought we might do
uh marcus this is i don't know this is
the fourth or fifth just heard the
background a bit uh we just felt that
with everybody locked down and staying
in their homes uh it's nice to connect
with people uh different people are
doing different things
i see by the way you know we're in the
lumber business mark was telling me that
someone told him that
the mills on vancouver island are busy
shipping cedar to the united states
because do it do-it-yourself projects uh
you know are booming like never before
people have time on their hands
i know that my wife who likes to make
sourdough bread at home can't get her
hands on any flour because everybody is
deciding to make flour and make bread at
home
so people are getting into all kinds of
activities including language learning
which is a very good way to spend your
uh lockdown moments and so we thought
we'd reach out to different users of
link and language learners so that they
could share what they're doing
and that might be encouraging for uh
other people so i just thought i would
so people know what these things are all
about
and you know what we might even have
time after isaac i don't know where del
wall is but um
if he doesn't show we may have time to
have some audience uh participation
maybe
uh okay if people are interested in in
uh and joining as a doing a bit of a uh
presentation uh
put your put your hand up i think
there's an ability to put your hand up
here somewhere
uh and with that maybe isaac you can go
ahead
so hello everyone isaac trollinger i've
been interested in languages for some
time i
when i was probably i don't know 10 11
12 i decided i was going to learn a
bunch of languages by using dictionaries
which did not work out
but i learned a lot about languages
and so i took that with me the last
couple years when i was in college i
minored in french and although i've most
of my french is now dormant i reached a
decent proficiency in french that gave
me confidence that i could learn pretty
much any language i wanted to
so shortly after that i started working
on spanish pretty seriously i'm not
fluent but i'm very happy with my
progress in spanish
and so
i've been using mostly duolingo and link
to work on spanish and whatever other
language i'm working on at the time
okay
can i make a couple of comments
absolutely i think this idea of dormant
is key people often say so how do you
maintain your languages
i don't i don't worry about them
if i start one up again i will struggle
but it is there and it comes back and it
very often comes back stronger than ever
and it's almost as if and other people
have agreed with this that spending time
on another language sort of expanding
your brain developing more flexibility
maybe a better capability of learning
languages in general
i mean all of that means that when you
go back to that in your case dormant
french very quickly you'll be back up
past where you were before so i always
say don't worry about stuff that's
dormant dormant is good
it's not going anywhere you can always
go back to it and the other thing you
said which caught my attention was the
word confidence and i think confidence
is so important
all people who are successful at
language learning are confident that
they can learn
and the people who are not so successful
who have been going to the library
spanish class for eight years and still
can't speak they basically somewhere
deep down don't think that they can do
it
so and if you've never done it in your
case you had that confidence from your
experience with french and then spanish
if you've never done that you just have
to give yourself the benefit of the
doubt
just do it and and you'll do it and once
it's done
you'll have that confidence and that was
certainly my experience after i
achieved a certain level in french i had
no doubt that i could do it for another
language which turned out to be chinese
so confidence is big
absolutely
okay
mark
yeah so you please please go ahead by
the way i i i like the suit and uh or
jacket and bow tie
in these cove at times uh you know
everybody
can like myself looking pretty casual so
bringing our level up a bit i i like
that
the only thing is we know that isaac has
his pajama pants underneath so
there was a question mark about could
isaac do something i saw that where did
i see that
well i mean isaac you're gonna you're
you're gonna
continue right
steve something you said about when you
switch from one language to another uh
that coming back to that it helps with
the first language right i had an
interesting experience with that um for
a while i was working on german and i've
i've i can't hardly speak german but i
can understand a little bit of it right
and early on i struggled with some of
the grammar concepts until i started
working on latin a little bit and in
latin with all the declensions
it finally clicked oh this is what's
going on in german
and to a lesser extent but based on that
i um
it allowed me
to
you know
improve in my german just by knowing how
the concept works yep and as i continue
to branch out and move into slavic
languages i'm sure that's already
something i'm finding that's coming up
more and more as a declension but since
i now know how it works and it's not
something that
is unknown to me i can approach that
with more confidence
because early on
before i before i had my success with
french when i tried to learn spanish i
would get a book and i would read it and
i would see conjugations and have no
idea how it worked it was just it was
foreign to me but coming out of english
but then going through college learning
the french conjugations going into
spanish it was something that oh i've
seen this before
it's different words same concept
i believe there was a question about me
sharing my screen screen i'm using a
cell phone so i'm not going to be able
to do that okay
but i will say one thing i have really
found helpful on link
is that the import feature
as a christian i'm pretty familiar with
the bible and i've found the bible in
different languages that i can pull in
so here's a passage i'm used i'm
familiar with in english all of a sudden
i can find it in almost any language i
want to learn
and i know what it's saying in english
but how is it saying it in
german or french or whatever other
language so i've really found that to be
interesting and i'm just i'm a pretty
new
premium link user so i'm still learning
feeling my way through and finding out
what to do but i've found that to be
something that is
pretty interesting for me you know
that's an interesting comment i think
people underestimate the importance of
familiarity
so obviously when we're learning a
foreign language we're learning
something that's strange because it's
different
the more things that are familiar the
better we're going to understand the
better we're going to do
in fact there have there were studies
done
where they took 20 or whatever 40 people
and they divided them into two groups
one group were allowed to study all the
new words in a passage ahead of time
and the other group was familiar with
the context
the group that was familiar with the
context understood much better than the
group that studied all the words
so familiarity is very important and
that's why a lot of people i know mark
has done harry potter in japanese or you
know and and so it's very useful to do
stuff that's familiar
that's another reason why for example
with our mini stories at link we talk
about very familiar situations you get
up you have a cup of coffee you drive to
work these are familiar
unfortunately many language books begin
say in korean by telling you that there
are four different ways of saying sister
so this is culturally so strange
you know or they got folk tales or they
got whatever and things that are very
very specific to this culture they feel
that you want to be hit chapter one with
all these different things whereas
actually you should be given very
familiar things
because you can always get back to the
fact that they have four ways of saying
sister
later on when you've learned the
language so familiar is key and i can
see that bringing in the bible in
different languages is uh is a great
thing to do yeah
and that's all i have right now okay
okay
that's great uh
i i don't see any uh anyone from the
audience wanting to uh participate
i'm not uh
but
if you're out there and you'd like to to
pop in say hello explain a bit about how
you use link uh no pressure otherwise
we'll uh
we'll continue along oh here's a
question
yeah
i i've been learning english with link
uh brett steve's blah blah blah but
recently it's a feeling i make no
progress what could i do would it be
better to read text out loud or silently
okay first of all
we have to remember the three stages of
learning
two or three the first stage is a period
where we make a lot of progress we think
we're you know we had a lot of trouble
before we've made a breakthrough we're
very pleased with ourselves then we
enter
a period that's known as either the
plateau or the desert or the doldrums
where we feel we're not making progress
but we are making progress you just have
to trust that you're making progress i
can tell that i'm making progress
with my arabic because the pages are
getting whiter and whiter on link fewer
and fewer blue words fewer and fewer
yellow words but whenever i listen to
the podcast from al jazeera or whatever
it might be i still don't understand it
so it's frustrating and it seems there's
forever words that i'm looking up or
there's yellow words that i still don't
know what they mean
even though i've met them many times so
it takes a long time so as to what you
should do i would continue doing what
you're doing if you want to read text
out loud do so i have never been able to
do that for very long but it is and not
it's a variety of activity do it to vary
your activities perhaps you're getting
bored sometimes if i'm bored with the
content that i'm using i'll go to our
uh you know uh
what's it called again not the stream
but the uh
the
the feed and i'll see what other people
are studying so get some variety bring
some variety into it you just have to
continue so you have to vary it maybe
talk a couple of times a week with the
tutor
vary the content you're using if you
want to read out loud do so i don't
think it's a
significant thing to do but if if you
enjoy doing it do so
so introduce a little more variety but
just remember that you are in that long
period where you are gradually but
slowly adding words your brain is slowly
getting used to the language you don't
have the impression that you're
improving but in fact you are and and i
would say that's that's why uh uh uh we
have a lot of the statistics that you
see on linked so that you actually see
that you're making progress so you can
see obviously that you're
creating links and and
you know
the so-called during the so-called
doldrums you should be creating a lot of
links uh and then likewise you should
start to see as steve said your page is
getting lighter but your known words
should be increasing because
as you continue to read and create links
and and go through content you realize
that you start you you know a lot of the
yellow words and and start moving them
to known and so these statistics and you
can go to your profile and you can see
over time your progress you see that
that your links graph is continues to
move up and to the right your known
words graph continues to move up and to
the right you should be doing the
listening you know 30 40 minutes a day
so your listening stats should move up
and to the right reading words of words
read all of those indicators tell you
that you are improving and uh you just
got to stay with it and and you just
realize you understand better over time
it's a gradual process yep
i'm just going to say one of the easiest
things to do is to create more links
because
it's mechanical okay the yellow words i
can't just move them to known if i don't
know them
and i come across them and i still don't
know them i still don't know them i i
don't know how many times i've come
across this word and i still don't
remember what it means
but you can create turn blue words into
yellow so you throw them into your
database you don't know it you haven't
learned it but at least if the goal is
13 links a day 50 links a day it's a
mechanical task it's like take out the
garbage you got to do it so you just do
it so at least today i achieved that i
created my 20 links or whatever your
goal is so i think that's another way of
attacking it and i think one of the
things people don't uh realize is and
don't maybe
do enough of is creating likes a lot of
people kind of create links slowly and
kind of pick and choose words to link
and then kind of really think that
they're gonna try and learn them
and and that's not that's not the right
approach the right approach is to create
as many links as you can work through
content the links if they matter will
come up again and they'll come up in the
next lesson and the words that don't
matter you'll never see them again it
doesn't matter that link is off
somewhere
but the words that matter that you see
regularly and it may be
uh influenced obviously by the type of
topics that you're interested in you'll
start to learn the vocabulary that you
need to learn to go through the lessons
that you're studying but definitely um
you know if you take a look at steve
statistics or any of our power users a
lot of the people
that that appear on these
gathering
uh panels
the number of links that they're
creating
it's just an indicator to create that
many links you're doing a lot of
listening you're doing a lot of reading
you're you're just
inputting a lot of content in your brain
and your brain will make sense of it
and if if you have trouble meeting your
daily link total uh create links with
phrases
go in there go back into text that
you're working on and
and create some phrase links
to meet that content that link creating
goal
now here michael comes back and says i
understand but this cannot know if i'm
reading books
of course
uh
yeah we can't the link can't track what
you're doing outside of link
but if you understand 80 of uh john
grisham's book
you're doing pretty well uh although if
you are reading john grisham's book i i
mean i if i'm reading a book in a
foreign language i import it into link
just it's just so would i eighty percent
for sure
for sure like
it's it's gonna work depending on where
you got the book from but uh you have to
figure out how to remove the the drm but
uh you can do a good google search to
try and figure out how to do that and
then get it into link and it's it's just
so much more pleasant to read the
foreign language books and link with the
ease of look up and it's just tied in
and gathers all your stats all the rest
of it and and um yeah i i don't read
foreign books foreign language books if
i can't read them on link and 80
actually is not very high
when i think of it now because
let's say you're at 95
so i don't know how many words there are
on a page
if there are 300 words on a page or
something
95
that means there's 15 words on that page
that you don't understand
now it might be the same word twice but
10 to 15 words is annoying actually i
think in order to enjoy reading away
from link i want to have like 99
if i'm at 95 percent known words
in a book i want to read that book on
link
and i'll find it as an e-book and
hopefully be able to import it
rodney asks are books on audible
downloadable into link
uh
so
no the answer is no and typically
at least my typical approach with books
is that i will
listen to books on audible so i'll find
books on audible
that look interesting and then i will go
and try and find the e-book
somewhere like buy the ebook and then
remove the drm and import it into link
and then i'll listen on audible
and read it on link and
i typically don't
in that situation read and listen at the
same time although i suppose you could
have audible playing in the background
and uh and read it on your
mobile device
but um i'll read it on link and then
when i'm whatever exercise you're
washing dishes i i'll listen on audible
um yeah it would be nice at some point
in the future if we could do some kind
of integration with
timestamping or amazon so that we could
maybe sell book text and audio together
in link already but that is one of our
dream scenarios that we will hopefully
achieve someday
um
hopefully that answers that question
steve
leroy rose asks do you review your links
what should i do with them when i have
created them
so
i at an early stage in the language i
will review them as i turn the page
very rarely like i'll occasionally go to
the vocabulary section and go through
them alphabetically somewhere randomly
there will be 3 000 links there
and so all the words that start with the
same letter
occasionally but so rarely that it
doesn't count mostly i'm reviewing my
words when i come across them in the
text
and sometimes when i turn the page but
as i advance in the language there's
just too many of them i don't i don't
really have to be honest i don't
i don't review them
and and i guess you know one of the
things that you do and have said and do
even when you're reviewing is you
actually don't care if you get them
right or not no you're just going
through them as fast as you possibly can
just to kind of remind yourself of the
word and the meaning which is why when
you go through a text and you click on
yellow words you're effectively doing
the same thing you click it see oh yeah
that's what it is move on see i could be
wrong but i'm of the opinion that all of
the scratching your brain thinking
trying to remember it doesn't do much
for you
that language learning is all about
exposure
so that's why i never do drills
questions comprehension questions any
kind of drill question where i got to
think about stuff
never
even the questions the circling
questions in the mini stories are all
about exposure
and the same with if i do flash carding
to introduce some variety because i'm
bored of
reading it's just bing bing bing i just
go through them quickly
i get them wrong i get them right it
doesn't matter it's just another form of
exposure
um
i just want to answer another question
here that before i uh lose it does your
language learning
acquisition principles apply to other
areas of life
so
i think that learning like my and i'd be
interested in isaac's point of view on
this but i think that the way we learn
things it doesn't matter what it is
there there's obviously some similarity
there the brain slowly starts to
you know get used to things uh you know
when i was at university uh
if i had a history course i would like
to get three or four different books on
the same subject so then i would get the
same material covered in three or four
different ways rather than trying to
master the one book
i would want to read a variety of books
that cover the same material and i think
this sort of grazing approach to
learning where you don't try to block
learn things
but you try to kind of
see it from this perspective and that
perspective go off do something else
come back
which is the right approach and never
worrying about what we master and ace
uh you know i think that works in in
learning a number of other things as
well that's my experience i don't know
if
other people
have other
ideas on that
if i may
oh go ahead go ahead isaac
so to me i guess language learning is a
little bit of a different animal than
say the other kind of learning i may be
doing in that with language learning i'm
really building up familiarity with the
language and building up enough
familiarity with the vocab that if i'm
put in a situation where i have to use
it whether it's in reading or speaking
i'm able to bring that out in a coherent
fashion if i'm learning to do something
else say
play piano or something like that it's a
little
different process
the principles of putting in the time
of
going over stuff enough that it becomes
familiar i think are the same
but
to me the end goal being
some form of fluency whether in reading
writing or speaking is different than
to me and to the other areas that i
might be seeking mastery again
yeah no they the the net result is
different but i mean the idea is about
you have to be positive you have to have
confidence you have to like it you have
to put in the time you should vary your
activities don't get frustrated at what
you can't do think more about what you
have achieved
i think all of those things are similar
and that's kind of anything yeah
hitting things from from from different
angles you know you like you have to
learn things three different times or
you know what whatever it is like the
first time it's it doesn't quite stick
and and so
uh
yeah definitely i i agree the idea that
your brain will learn and you just need
to kind of hit it enough times
and trying to force it to stick
it doesn't really work not for the you
know especially in
you know with vocabulary a lot of people
really want to
you know get
interested in the srs and reviewing and
the reality is if you if you go after
srs and you're going to review and
you're going to
manage your statuses and and
and learn them till you you know
whatever it is that the anki or whatever
it is uh
you cannot possibly learn enough words
that way you you just it's just not an
efficient process even if it does work
to learn those
20 words today or whatever it is
like 20 words a day is just not enough
you you you want to get to 35 000 45 000
words so 20 words a day that's
plus i think the idea that you are
learning the words in context so you're
also exposing yourself to all of that
context so that you're getting familiar
with the language even as you're
learning the words now there are certain
things that are quite different from
language learning like you know if
you're learning judo
so you've got to practice these
movements and you want to nail them down
so that they become automatic
and that you can train your body to do
these things so i think training the
body for certain physical activities
in sports for example working on your
serve in tennis or or your slap shot in
hockey is different language learning is
more of a fuzzy process in my opinion
so i guess to finish that guy's question
yes it's worthwhile to move on for sure
if you're bored of a lesson or move on
you don't need if you
understand 75 85 move on to something
else even if you understand less move on
keep moving come back
keep moving forward come back but create
lots of links
vary the input all of those things will
produce better results than just trying
to hammer at one lesson and nail it down
to perfection
uh somebody also asked just a follow-up
to the audible and audio or they were
the ebook question i have legal copies
of harry potter
can i import them into link
the answer is absolutely yes
um
there's no issue importing into link but
of course you shouldn't share those in
the library because
yeah you you you've
bought them and and you can use them for
your own use
but
but
other users should buy them and import
them for their own use
um
but there's no there's no there's no
restrictions on importing anything you
want for your own account it's private
and and not shared unless you actively
choose to share it
someone is asking what are the
statistics on the effectiveness of
learning english using link
of course following all the
recommendations and all the tips given
by you steve
uh there are no statistics
um
i think that um
it's widely recognized that massive
input
uh
and these are the theories of stephen
krashen um and others
massive and the experience of many
people massive input massive listening
reading is the most effective way of
learning a language
uh link makes that easier to do there's
a bunch of functions a bunch of
statistics there's a range of content
available there for you uh you can
import uh material
but we have no statistics we haven't
done any studies we haven't asked any
university to compare have two groups
people on duolingo and people on link
and at the end of six months who's
learned the most we haven't done
anything like that so we have no such
statistics
as a native english speaker
learning french
is in terms of vocabulary isn't a huge
issue the bigger issue is understanding
spoken speech especially with the
crossover words because i've done so
much listening in russian it's become
easier to understand it but russian is
phonetic unlike french so will it take
longer to understand french speech i
can't understand it
if it'll take more time to get used to
it
well the thing to understand about
french is that it is one of the most
monotonous languages
like you don't have a lot of
tone intonation it's like
so that takes a while to get used to
and
there is this liaison which you're
talking about you know
in other words if it says you know
it's
like the last sound of the previous
words slams right into the beginning of
the next word you just have to get used
to that you have to listen to it and and
listen and read and maybe it helps
if you uh
take a paragraph
say in lesson at link and listen to
the
natural speech the narrator and then
ver just a paragraph or even a sentence
and then try and imitate that imitate
that imitate the intonation imitate the
liaison just get yourself to try and do
what the native speaker is doing
and gradually your brain will get used
to it you have to assume that your brain
will get used to all of these things
there are people who have learned french
so
you but it yes you have identified a
problem
with russian the problem is cases are
you know verbs of motion or something in
french it's this
you just have to get used to it that's
how they speak you just have to get used
to it
and a lot of listening just a lot of
listening a lot of listening you have to
hear it enough that your brain starts to
make sense of it
i guess we'll keep moving on
what do you think is the main difference
between link and other similar programs
what is its advantage
um
yeah i i don't know of of many other
what we would consider to be similar
programs that are out there um typically
people are comparing link to
you know i guess your duolingos and
babbles and um
you know i don't know i guess anki
flash card review
um obviously we're
we're we're a bit uh biased
but uh
yeah i mean i i don't think you can
really compare effectiveness i mean
those other programs are very limited in
what they are going to teach you it's
they're good to get you
uh interested in the language and i you
know they're they're gamified and and um
but the the the
even if you
complete those other apps you're only
covering this much of the language when
you need you know you can't see my arms
but this much
uh you need
tens of thousands of words you need the
listening you know you know i don't know
how many hours of of you know a thousand
hours of listening to
real content in that language you need
to read
hundreds of thousands of words
effectively at least that's what you do
on link so that you can achieve that
exposure that you need to be able to
speak understand
and eventually speak uh in your target
language and and so i think the big
thing that sets link apart is is that
a we make it interesting through the
content
and and b
it's a platform that will let you
achieve whatever
level you are trying to achieve in your
target language
i don't know if the steve you're going
to add to it it's it's some people like
it some people don't for me i find it a
pleasant place to be you know you have
to be in an environment that you enjoy
where you enjoy the activity you want to
get back to it
and so i think that some people are
comfortable in duolingo and some people
are comfortable in link
here's a
question do you use link for english
also sometimes there are new words you
can learn in your native language steve
well i don't first of all i i would like
to improve in all of my languages
including english so i don't have time
to go back and improve in japanese so
i'm not going to spend any time on
english but i have often thought that
because
so many people
in any society
are
are not uh let's say are not as literate
as as they could be in their own
language in terms of their vocabulary
and their use of language it's estimated
that 20 of the population in advanced
countries
has you know is in that lowest tier in
terms of literacy so i've often felt
that link would be useful
as part of a literacy program to help
people read better in their native
language which if it was english then
that would be the case for english but i
don't use it for that
uh here's some questions from my youtube
how long should you read and listen
before you start talking
i think that's entirely subjective and
in fact that ties into uh i'll tie that
into a question i see on the q a when
can you stop learning and start
functioning in the language and not try
to learn things okay
you never stop learning and start
functioning you're always doing both so
you don't stop listening and reading and
start speaking even when you start
speaking you're still focusing on
listening and reading you get the
language in you through listening and
reading
when you start speaking is entirely up
to you as an individual when are you
comfortable so in my case i spent nine
months listening and reading to russian
before i spoke
i had no didn't feel any pressure to
speak i was enjoying
the content that i was reading and
listening to and i saw my
comprehension ability go up and then i
started speaking with check it was six
months
now that we have the mini stories which
is kind of our starter material i found
i find that they get
get me going faster because there's so
much repetition
so many
high frequency verbs conjunctions
that i'm so i used to start speaking
with when i had ten thousand words with
czech it was like seven or eight
thousand words and now i start with
three thousand words
however if you live where the language
is spoken or if you want to start
earlier i think that's a very much a
subjective thing but
if you're not if you don't live with the
languages spoken your opportunity to
speak is basically getting online with
someone either a language exchange or a
tutor that you pay well you can't spend
three hours a day well maybe you can but
it's difficult to spend three hours a
day online talking to people
so it's still going to be a minor part
of your learning
once or twice a week the bulk of the
learning to my mind
remains the listening and reading
activity
and as to when you start i think that's
entirely up to you as i as i said i used
to be eight ten thousand words now i'm
at three thousand words and that's
by and large because of the many stories
how do you see the future of online
language teaching what should teachers
try to do
well
in my own view
historically
the teacher taught the language so i'm
sitting in the class i don't know
anything about the language i don't know
what words mean i don't know the
subjunctive i don't know the cases i
know nothing the teacher is the source
of information about the language
today that's no longer the case
i can
first of all i i find that i get into
the language better by listening to
things rather than having some
explanation rather than saying today
we're going to do
uh you know verbs or irregular verbs
tomorrow we're going to do subjunctive
in other words where there's a definite
program of teaching the grammar i don't
find that very effective i get into the
language through say many stories when
i'm curious about the language
i look it up so the role of the teacher
to me
is to encourage
to help the learner find content at
their level
something that we hope to do better at
link
content that's relevant interesting and
yet at my level
uh answer any questions
uh
keep you know maintain the motivation of
the student many students start with a
lot of motivation and then their
motivation declines teacher has to make
sure that they're constantly motivated
as i often say when i was 16 i spoke one
language then i had a teacher who really
motivated me to learn french and that
started me onto learning these other
languages so an online tutor has to be
aware of what resources are available
online for that language how to motivate
the student
and those kinds of things rather than
seeing themselves as someone who's going
to teach the language
uh yeah i mean i guess one of the things
we always say is that
no one can teach you the language you
need to learn it but the the teacher can
really help you by pointing you pointing
out how you can learn it because
you know people people don't don't know
how
you know
that
how reading and listening is so
effective uh for example
um
yeah anyway uh
any plans for african languages no no
plans for african languages but i think
we covered this i guess the last
gathering but um yeah if we if we get
many stories in
african languages prepared
by volunteers then we'll look at what
would be involved in in adding them on
link but right now we have no plans
somebody asked here why do you suggest
for getting used to different accents in
chinese
most of the intermediate content i find
is deliberately spoken in a slow and
clear manner i suspect then this
intermediate content is not authentic
content you're going to have to go
maybe on youtube or somewhere and find
natural content
where there are transcripts bring them
into link and undoubtedly you're going
to come across different accents
there'll be some taiwanese there'll be
some people from eastern china from
southern china
and you're just going to have to look
for that
maybe you could ask on our forum at link
but i'm not studying chinese so i don't
know where you would go to find that
material
where is a good place to buy audiobooks
for link
uh just i guess it depends on the
language audible was mentioned earlier
which is has a lot of audiobooks in a a
variety of languages you then still have
to find the ebook somewhere else
unfortunately the
ability to buy at audiobook with text
it's not really something that anyone
seems to offer
uh so you end up having to get the audio
in one place and the e-book is somewhere
else or you have to at least buy them
separately
um yeah i mean besides the obvious
audible amazon um
you know there's
depending on words in every country
depends on the language for russian it's
liters
l-i-t-r-e-s which is excellent for czech
and polish there was audioteca which had
a lot uh
publio.pl for polish i mean you just
have to you know search in the target
language search for audiobooks and
ebooks if you don't know how to say
those things in the target language go
to google translate get it translated
then pop it into google
and
yeah go ahead i would just say that and
we're going to be trying
as we move forward to do a better job of
helping people find these resources
um through our interface to try and
point people at them because it's not
that easy to find them uh especially
depending on the language that you're
studying so uh we're gonna try to get
you know we have lots of members who do
find these things and try to figure out
how we can
put that information together in a
central location or on make it available
on link so that people have an easier
time of finding that this guy's into the
question about spanish material from
rodney
uh
yeah he's looking for beginner material
i think if you're still looking up 60 of
the words rodney you're better off to
stay in our library at link we have lots
of spanish content build up your you
know known words count with our own
material
and then you'll be i think more
successful in finding stuff online that
you can import
uh somebody else i have a number of easy
activities that i enjoy doing in chinese
and french do you think i might waste my
time also i like to review a lot how
much review is too much
yeah i don't know what do you mean by
easy activities that you enjoy doing i
mean i think if you enjoy doing them
that's a positive thing it's time spent
with the language
but i guess if it's not improving your
level much then uh at least you should
be also including
some activities that are are difficult
or at least you know you should be on
link and trying to do
content with more new words so that
you're
pushing yourself a bit there's some
variety like a little bit of variety
between easy content to improve your
fluency and more difficult content
uh to push your level i think is
definitely worth doing as far as
reviewing a lot again if you like
reviewing
uh you know it's not a bad thing but we
we certainly believe that moving on to
new lessons and seeing those yellow
links in new contexts
uh multiple new contexts is is a more
efficient way of a learning the
vocabulary and then getting more
exposure to listening and reading in in
your target language i mean i could say
that i basically have two activities
listening and reading
okay and when i'm reading i'm looking up
words and i'm looking reviewing my
yellow links
those are the fundamental activities and
within that as mark says vary it every
so often you're bored of the easy
content you go and take on some
difficult content lots of new words you
get tired of fighting your way up
fighting your way through the bramble
bush
getting scratches all over your back
so you retreat to the easy stuff
and you listen to that a few times and
you notice a few things then you get
bored with that and then you go back to
the difficult stuff
um
[Music]
yeah i think we covered this how you
teach english effectively given your
views about language learning
well
bear in mind that i haven't been a
classroom teacher but i have done online
tutoring
and so i try to engage the learner
you know in in conversation trying to
get the learner to speak it's one-on-one
so it's not a classroom
in a classroom i guess you'd get
everyone trying to speak more and then i
make note of the
phrases and the words that the learner
has trouble with i i type these into my
con conversation report that link as the
person is talking so at the end i have
like 20 or more phrases and then i
record that forum or her send it out to
them and that's a lesson that they study
that's good enough i don't find
correcting all that useful
i find myself when i review my
conversation reports over six months i
seem to make the same mistake
it's interesting because the com
my tutor
will write out all the phrases that i
have trouble with
because my ability to use words is much
more limited than my comprehension we
tend to talk about the same subjects
because i'll steer the conversation back
to things that i can talk about and then
i'll make the same mistakes every week
so i'll see the same corrected stuff
every week it takes a long time to
correct yourself and i've had the same
experience in teaching people i correct
them and they continue making the same
mistake right in the very same class
after i corrected them so realistically
i think
engaging with a teacher it's encouraging
it's motivating the good teachers are
motivating they get me to talk i don't
have to think up questions the teacher
gets me talking i get a report i review
it it's just part of that gradual
process i think that's what teachers
should do encourage
uh perhaps provide some
input for the learner
and
help them with with suggestions on where
to find content
and this is what my good teachers have
done in the tutors that i've used on
link
here's a question for isaac did you find
did you find just passages rather than
the entire entire bible if so where did
you find the bible passages in other
languages
so i found there's a website called
bible gateway and it has
dozens if not hundreds of different
translations um most of them are the
whole bible some are just new testament
now one thing i did do when i was using
that was i went through and checked the
copyright to make sure i wasn't using
one that said
you know you can only use it for this
that's this use i found one that just
had a general copyright on it and then
and imported those over
so
uh
there are some languages that are not on
there but i
i found uh a lot of languages that i'm
interested in on there and i can find so
in what i would do is pull over one
chapter at a time my test was whether or
not uh
psalm 119 which is the longest chapter
of the bible could fit in one single
lesson on link
so i pulled it out in a certain language
on a word doc checked it and put it in
and indeed it did fit on one lesson and
so then from then on i just i knew if it
could handle psalm 119 it could handle
any other chapter and i just brought
over the ones that i'm interested in and
went from there
in terms of uh by the way a copyright i
mean if you're importing for your own
use it it really shouldn't matter what
the copyright restrictions are i i
believe um just as a
as i know obviously if you share if
you're sharing them in the library
that's a different story than yes for
sure you need to check the copyright
restrictions
uh thanks isaac
let's see i've studied german for a
month now i'm getting more confident by
the day but i've heard you should wait a
little before starting to talk i guess
we've covered this how long should i
wait
uh
i mean did you actually give a you just
said whenever whenever you want if
you're you know burning with desire to
talk start talking if you're not quite
comfortable yet then wait at some point
you have to speak and to become fluent
you have to speak a lot at some point
and that may involve going to the
country
because once or twice a week with a
tutor is not going to do it but
typically
after a while you're curious you know
and and it's it's always very
interesting like if i've been three
months on
you know persian and i set up my first
uh
online tutoring session i'm a little
nervous like am i going to be able to
say anything in this language and
inevitably i do much better than i
expect
and and recently i had the experience of
not talking with the tutor in arabic or
persian for six months
and then i get back on and the
tutor is surprised how much i've
improved haven't even spoken in the
interim
so listening and reading improves your
ability to speak
when you first start speaking you
struggle and then it develops but as to
when you start i think that's entirely
personal i now start when i have 3 000
words
and have gone through the 60 mini
stories
i used to wait till i had eight or ten
thousand words but it's up to each
person
uh i
how can i learn chinese as fast as
possible it's uh i guess getting uh
getting on my nerves
i'm not able to remember
uh the romanizations letters sounds even
with anki
you know i think one of the i always
quote manfred spitzer i got his book
somewhere here anyways he is this german
neuroscientist
and he says the brain learns
the brain cannot do otherwise than learn
the brain he calls it is a pattern
extracting machine
if you give the brain enough stimulus
it's going to start sorting things out
patterns
he points out that they did research
with a one-year-old child one-year-old
child can 90 percent accurately identify
which structures in a language belong to
his or her native language that's how
good the brain is at identifying
patterns
so
that's the child but he says the brain
learns but the brain learns slowly
so it's absolutely pointless to be
frustrated that you're not learning as
quickly as you would like
you will learn as quickly as you will
learn
and
i would i because i don't use anki
because i don't use that approach
uh i use the approach of lots of
listening and reading
and with that the brain slowly gets
accustomed to the language
with regard to characters though i did
use a spaced repetition system to learn
the most frequent 1000 characters and
thereafter i didn't
but
you know do a lot of listening and
reading and and you you may have to do
something specific on characters because
learning characters is
different from
learning words come on because they're
not phonetic they don't represent the
sounds you're not hearing
necessarily the the sort of um
a sound version of what is written it's
it's a little more disconnected so
chinese is more difficult in that sense
but you just have to say the course
another question about importing ebooks
with audio from amazon i mean
first of all
i guess i guess the on on the kindle
there is an ability to listen to the
books and i'm not sure exactly how that
works but um
if you buy an ebook
on
uh
your kindle
yeah you just have to look up how to
remove the drm and then
there are instructions on on link on how
to import
the different ebook files like um epub
and and or even text or pdf files uh but
you will have to remove the the
protection and and you'll have to google
search how to do that for the
different book
um
sellers
um they don't they don't make it easy
but it it's if you make the effort and
figure out how to do it it's it's really
great to have the books inside link
because it just makes the
the um just it just
is a great way to read foreign language
books
uh so yes you can do it
it's it
we don't think there's any
issue with importing books ebooks that
you buy into link for your own use
obviously don't share them in the
library
but you bought them for your own use to
then import them into link and read them
there because it works better i think
is fine so yes you're able to but you
may have to do some googling to figure
out how to remove the drm
um
yeah a lot of similar questions how to
break through the intermediate barrier i
think we covered that plateau question
similar question earlier should i note
down vocab words explicitly note down i
mean that's what you do on link you
create links for the vocab words that
you're trying to learn so the answer is
yes but you do it using a system i mean
writing them down on paper is obviously
a lot less
effective
um
i import a lot of youtube videos is
there any way to stop link from always
restarting video playback whenever i
switch between normal and sentence mode
i believe that um
that may depend on which platform you're
using i'm trying to think now
um
i don't uh
yeah i can't remember but um
yeah
we should check that but i believe that
uh on the web
you actually it does do that
um at any rate um yeah if they're you
know maybe send us an email and let us
know which platform you're using and
we'll check and see what's what's going
on there
uh but probably
sentence mode
depending
again on the
um platform you're using sentence mode
allows you to actually watch the video
while you read the lesson which i think
most people if you're if you're doing a
video and want to watch
as you read that works better
obviously
um on full page mode
the video covers the
text at least on your phone
um although i guess on the web and on
your on on a tablet it it would be
available in the sidebar
um anyway yeah reach out to support and
and and point out which devices is
giving you that problem
language classes why do they fail they
remain popular as a starting point
you know
most people to learn a language go to
school
that's the natural thing to do
that's what people normally do they go
to class that's what they're used to
doing
uh they don't all fail either i mean a
motivated learner is gonna learn in
class
uh it's just that people aren't very
motivated aren't necessarily motivated
by going to class
um
i don't know
i i would i you know juxtaposed that
question with this comment here from
jilly he says i just started learning
german by many stories that link the
result was awesome different from doing
a
grammar at the beginning
blah blah blah
so yeah it's
people are not so familiar with our
approach people are more familiar with
the idea that you go to a class and the
teacher teaches you the language and
because it's difficult to teach a
language
therefore for many people that situation
is not successful
i would say too that i think that
mindset is is changing especially you
know with today's
scenario where people aren't able as
able to go to class i mean i think
people are more and more looking for at
apps and looking at software
recognizing that you can do a lot on
your own and even those students who go
to class and are successful actually
achieve a lot of their success outside
of class
classroom motivates them to actually put
the effort in outside of class to
consume material in their target
language
uh the types of things that we we do on
links so so that i mean
there are benefits to being in class you
get that social interaction you you you
you if you have a teacher that motivates
you that's all great the ability to
speak face to face
um and but link is a great
accompaniment to any uh language class
scenario because it gives you the
opportunity to really
dive deeper and and and spend more time
with with the target language that's
just the exposure that you get which you
can't get unless you move to that
country and spend your whole day in the
in the target language
social interaction is big no doubt you
know if you have your local you know
three times a week or one time a week
language class you meet your friends in
the classroom i mean it's it's a great
social
get-together
but it may take you half an hour to get
there on transportation half an hour to
get back so it's uh and it's called and
it costs so you have to weigh the pros
and cons of course if you're listening
to your linked lessons there and back
then that's
getting the best of both worlds
uh are are the brains being a
pattern-making machine do you think
during the beginning stages you should
expose yourself to a bigger massive
input or does it not matter much as long
as you get input
i didn't quite understand that i think
you're asking you mean at the beginning
should you expose yourself to more input
than you would later on i i don't think
so i mean you should continue to expose
yourself to as much input as you can
that just you'll just get better and
better
yeah i think you have to also maintain
that balance again quoting manfred
spitzer you need repetition and you need
novelty
so initially the language is new
i find that i have a high tolerance for
repetition as i'm into a new language
listening to the mini stories many many
times and after a while i just get bored
with them and so then i start to look
for new content and i'd listen less
often
less often so you have to at different
stages balance that repetition and
novelty but the basic principle is
you're just pounding
lots of the language into your brain and
the brain is then sorting through it
i see that burak ariel mazz
is has his hand up wanting to talk okay
good
oh
where'd he go maybe not
okay he's no longer okay maybe that was
uh
my mistake never mind
uh any more questions there on um
in the
qa box
[Music]
let's see
uh oh uh i'm new to link it's is it
based on mini story studying by
downloading storing phrases and
and clicking on dictionary uh i mean
mini stories is what we recommend people
start with obviously the library
is full of content and you you're
probably looking at only the beginner
stuff you can adjust your level filters
so that you can see intermediate
advanced stuff as you advance
and then and then as you advance of
course you you significantly increase
your
access to content by importing which we
definitely recommend and which our power
users uh definitely
take advantage of i mean
we can't possibly have
all the
interesting content out there to appeal
to every single person so if you can
find content that you're interested in
and import it you're you're
gonna be gonna be happier
um
i'm thinking about doing a 90-day
challenge in may i have a an hour an
hour and a half a day which do you
suggest
it's 11 o'clock uh you mean i guess i
between these the standard 90-day
challenge and the um
power i can't remember what we call it
um hardcore
90-day challenge uh an hour and a half a
day
uh
i i think you should be able to do
either one of those um
you know i don't know if that includes
listening time or not
um
if it's an hour and a half actively on
link you certainly will get through the
hardcore challenge
um either way you should an hour and a
half is is a good amount of time so uh
either either one of those challenges
where do you go to find sources to
listen to at the level where
you are example listen to lupus radio
ambulante but i find that i understand
so little i have to spend a lot of time
looking up 60 other words i'm looking
for sources
for books at the beginning level in
spanish
yeah i mean it's hard to find books at
the beginning level um
you kind of need to get a basic level
first before you're able to tackle books
uh we you know there may be some sort of
low intermediate
upper beginner type books in in spanish
might have stuff content like that
but that that sort of intermediate level
content is not that easy to to find
um
yeah depends how good the or motivated
you are to read that book like i i i
i know that in uh
even though you start out in a book
and you even with 60
unknown words if you really are
interested in the book you can kind of
it's painful at first
but you know within within a month you
you're amazed at how much faster you are
going through that book and after two
months you've kind of doubled your speed
again and
you you can kind of plow through books
if you're really motivated or go find
some easier content and work your way up
conversational content
books tend to be more vocabulary heavy
so it's not surprising that you're
hitting
unknown words i don't know steve
well yeah the comment i made earlier was
i think at that level uh that person is
better off to rely on stuff in our
library
and get the word count up so that your
books and other authentic material is
only
i mean anything over 20 unknown words is
tough
so i figure i always find 15 to be a
sweet spot where you're gaining enough
new words and yet it's not too
frustrating
more than 20 is just very tough so i
would go there's lots of spanish content
in our library just go for that
and build up your word count
okay i think probably with that i think
we're
we're we're um we've been at this for an
hour so i think it's probably a good
time to call it today okay uh
sorry we didn't get to every last
question but i think we've uh we covered
a lot and a lot of the themes keep
coming up
same themes can keep coming up so
thanks again everybody for joining in
thank you isaac for for sharing with us
uh everybody stay safe wherever you are
and um yeah happy linking we'll see you
next time okay bye
bye